it's hardly it's already the third
season of the detour and one of the
things that I've got it at this point
you guys as a cast must be incredibly
comfortable together it's just gotta I
mean after that much time yeah well yes
and our hours are so insane that we end
up spending entire days and weeks
together without any any breaks Jason
Jones who is the show's creator and the
male lead he and I play a married couple
and we the boundaries starts to get a
little fuzzy after a while yeah we we
did this I think it was the last week's
episode we had it he wrote a joke where
my characters were I'm getting married
and my character is wearing the
sweatpants with the bride the word bride
on the butt and everybody's favorite
yeah I wear those when I got there I
guess and the joke was that the the deep
the D in the bride was supposed to go
into my crack so that it said breathe
now you're listening I like it yeah
sorry I'm pervy yeah so we weren't able
to get to get the D in there and for
those of you just tuning in the joke
keeps going in my ass yeah so every
female on on set was trying to sort of
maneuver this thing to go in the thing
and so finally I said Jason you wrote
the joke we're gonna need your help with
this and he he was like I fit physically
yeah yeah he's like I have permission to
go in go in so so he's we're all trying
it and he was like oh yeah no you have a
shallow crack it's not gonna happen
like it's a deviated septum like
everybody knows about the shallow
crackers got a shallow praise fine we'll
just pick these like we see a lot of
these in the back
you